Sorry Sorry Sorry  welcome to America buddy okay I'll leave  a like oh there's everything watered  down or is it just the bear breathing  out of Cobra  all right everyone sit on your Fannie's  I don't know man wear whatever you want  shirt jacket pants okay dude why are you  wearing pants  you said to know I thought it was an LA  thing Oh  [Music]  [Music]  I'm sorry so do you fancy taking a  special place for a shag okay sure  use your shag Thanks why'd you any pants  I am wearing pants  wanna play some football  do i I don't want you wear like a shirt  and vest that look cool okay this isn't  what you meant either nope okay loves  white I mean that's probably why she's  married to Jeff right Holly what is  going on anonymous tip into the police  to ring in a wife-beater shop  [Music]  sorry  [Music]